puis viendra le temps m'ignore du poivre
et sel et du mironton celle là auront
appris la cuisine qui retient les petits
mari keith débit
[Musique]
donc nous allons faire dominique les
pattes au favori mais ça vous et c'est
ça tu vois à quel heure me michael roth
écoute je vais te dire faut pas te
priver de ça c'est le seul avantage que
présente cet animal s'y connait pas ton
pouce
on dira comment on va les faire cuire le
hohwald à nos poussées viva je mettais
en fait revoir la recette alors la base
ce sont les pâtes fraîches et tu peux
les faire au favori
les fabris est ce que tu viens de voir
sur les crabes remy dit qu on appelle ça
les familles si tu n'as pas de favori tu
les fais au moule s'est déjà préparé les
moore
elles sont toutes prêtes elles faire si
tu n'as pas de moule tu les fais au
clovis et s'il n'y a pas de club il
situe les faits au beurre voilà c'est
tout ti cats ou un maul faire alors on
va tout faire voir voilà tu enlèves les
pattes que tu me dises une casserole de
cinq ou six bestioles comme ça regarde
moins d'un mois en mois dépasse à peine
7 faisons dieu qu'elle est ça aussi le
cette optique c'est pas possible
voilà ça on est obligées de le faire
vivre
tu peux le refaire remords si on ne fait
rien le faut que sic lui aussi en voila
voila tu mets ça sur le feu oui tout
pâte est ce que tu sais faire des gains
alors tard dans la soirée le si j'ai mis
les pâtes des pâtes des pâtes l'huile on
voit quand on a mis un bon petit peu là
j'ajoute des tomates de la tomate
concassée ou pas coca c'est très bien je
mets 2 3 vous se taille toujours par le
quai est croisée avec la poêle jours
oui parce que ça a moins de boureij jeu
mais n'en a pas moins de nouveau sonné
dit jamais signé lors du laurier du et
les fenouils je fais trouver un peu de
poudre paix de l'âme c'est du thym frais
quand même un bain semaines prévient ça
va trop vite
voilà ben voilà rien c'est laisser
rêveur doucement c'est bien ça c'est
pour la sauce site ce sont des moules ou
tu mets les moules si ce soit des clovis
ultime et des quiz et qu'il garde un peu
d'eau de clovis regarde toi ça va être
parti tu gardes ou de l'aude et mouloud
et clovis des lacs cela mettrait tout à
l'heure un peu l'eau de la cuisson et
j'ai enlevé toutes les coquilles mais la
main pour faire mieux dans le plat ou
dans les restaurants privés le pas trop
se casser la tête ça fait mieux et c'est
moins long il vous a c'est l'eau qui est
en train de chauffer pour faire cuire
les pâtes fraîches et de l'huile
non je veux pas de lui le danger mais de
lui le dessus et c'est pourquoi lancé
claude batut vois que tu vas mettre
progressivement la farine puis l'aurait
vu ça il ya des choses que je ferais pas
expliqué voilà voilà mes pattes
l'eau est salée berlin tenue j'ai même
mis un peu le bouillon tu sais de ce
cube de bouillon la dame noire
alors maintenant tu écrases m'écrase
cinq ou six sept ou huit s'être favori
c'est la scène ça vous voilà voilà
s'agisse comme ça mais c'est pas brune
voilà voilà
et tu fais revenir tout ça si laisser
cuire à l'eau avant l'exemple insee a
pas le même goût et non sa part de
nouveau parce que tu sais je vais
nettoyer un peu le rajoute ou mono de
cuisson
c'est parti et c'est bien alors je dois
te dire maintenant que je vais rajouter
tous aussi favori parce qu'après on
parle de ses reins je vais te dire ça si
tu as le temps de le faire
c'est pas la ménagère qui rentrent le
soir chez elle car le temps de me
préparer tout ça on ne peut faire ouvrir
début des moules à l'arrière on peut
faire lourder clovis pendant qu'on dit
autre chose souvent tout seul mais si tu
dois faire tout ça tout les favoris
c'est pas possible c'est trop lente et
trop long alors je vais te donner un
truc
vas-y faits et gestes le don que ce soit
face il faudra répéter aperçoivent que
ce soit facile et rapide man fait alors
tu achètes c'est pat c'est pas trés
gastronomique mais c'est excellent tu
achètes voilà 65 de la soupe et oui ce
sont des messieurs
c'est un extrait de soupe de pois sort
mais tu t'en tiens pas pour faire de la
soupe de poisson parce que là sous
pression avec ça ferait un pas tellement
mais pour accompagner les pattes
c'est à dire faire vers la base de
taxation et tu rajoute un peu de beurre
oui et tu rajoute un peu d'huile d'olive
et puis 1 place des pâtes si tu as pas
le temps de faire autre chose moi je
vais te dire je préfère des boîtes et
bien moi je vais te dire je m'en serais
douté alors ça qu'ils le laissent partir
non loin de là dessus sur truc
électrique pendant que c'est cuit tout
cela maintenant on peut couper car cela
ne leur coûte rien
car pour rien je vais te faire voir
comment on peut faire on prépare les
moules pour karzaï dans les pattes
d'accord voilà entendu je prends une
poêle a tué jusqu'à hier je mets un peu
d'huile d'arachide d'arachide mélangé
avec un peu d'huile d'olive
tu peux mourir et garde un peu plus
voilà
voilà alors c'est là où tu prépares le
moule où tu vois par l'économiste ou
alors tu mettais moule ya un peu de ça
fait longtemps que ça bouge presque bien
en contre mais sans jamais vu l'autre
huit ans avec la bouche c'est toi qui
met le moule
tu les fais revenir à gaza et alors si
tu préfères je suis qui aimerait qu'ils
craignent c'est la cuisine du soleil
berenson du bienfait yahia qui craignent
un peu ce goût conduit l'homme ne livre
doléances à dans fortis est bon alors si
tu veux tu rajoutes tu les fais partie
robert c'est aussi par un oui ça doit
enlever un petit goût quand même un joli
jeu laurens sweeck mois le petit
couleurs d'accord je vous aime tous le
monde te voilà ça part très bien voilà
c'est reims et alors là tu les a mis
dans le mât s'est voulu rajouter un peu
poussé mes poireaux c'est allé trop fort
mais pour motiver lorsque vous avez pris
une pause dans les familles et tu mets 5
oui oui ça c'est toujours si tu as le
temps de le faire comme ça le fait rire
avec toi là tu fais important encore
c'est pas possible ça fait des petits
bouillons
après si tu mets tout les familles et
pour la sauce
c'est de se mouiller en d'une famille et
même qu'andorre parler gentiment à une
dame kamber lui prend la peine ma petite
famille alors tu vois tu vas te vivante
et où c'est pour ça c'est pour ça c'est
que ça va très loin qu'elles
voilà la sécu veut ça d'un coup tu fais
tes boules mais tu peux rajouter 2
gousses d'ail petit bouddha youtube aux
huitièmes plus corsier ou si tu préfères
lay down town
ça n'est pas obligatoire et la savane
effet pas cru utile et c'est juste bien
chauffé à petit feu comme ça voilà je
les fais oui si tu veux pousser le
raisonnement de plus loin tu peux même
les flots mais si tu veux personne
n'empêche
mais en fait ça rentre par oui non non
c'est chaud parce qu'il fait pas preuve
d'une heure mais alors ça me plaisait
pas trop mal acquis bien qu'il faut ça
je fais c'est pas celle ci parle c'est
pas le but
alors combien à peu près là en quantité
de moulinsart et du beaucoup il ya
peut-être de litres dans le midi ont
même pas les moules au litre à part de
sa semaine dans le nord bon je suis
moitié lydie moitié nord alors oui c'est
ça c'était un duel permanent dans le
midi ça se voit je voulais déjà dit
c'est parti quand ça c'est cuit sa place
au sein du bric louis s'est pas soucié
[Musique]
c'est tout toi ne va bouillir
je te le fais pas mais tu fais pareil
avec les clichés qui veut le faire au
club je n'ai pas du tout la l'huile de
cuisson là je vois c'est à dire sérieux
la réserve est offert les cobistes the
way ce que je veux dire toute économie
économie
voilà alors les sens bien dedans lui est
obligé de travailler un peu vite
d'accord voilà alors si les salaires
sont superbes
je vais mettre un peu non là dessus
parce que j'espère que ça va bouillir
faut que pour faire les pattes il faut
que ça vous a grand bouillonnement ça va
partir à la hausse
bien que lancée là on y voit là alors
tes pattes et bien tenue ce n'est pas
tout fraîche et sika par le terrain
d'aller chercher les pâtes fraîches ne
soutient pas la tannerie faire les
joutes à 2030 donner la recette et après
ce sera la tam préfère qu'on n'est pas
ordinaire
voilà où il ya écrit le temps des plus
chauds sur la boîte chez moi non six
comme un jeu tout le monde est voilà
c'est pas mis à part un kilo kg soit mis
à la pro a c'est à dire je vais te dire
non ça ça fait pour trine kg ça fait
pour 8 personnes qui m'arrive bien tu
vois ce que je vous dis ah oui ça
profite beaucoup et us partir de là et
tu les écarte bien et ça c'est important
et pas 90 comme espace group
je vais finir deux promus a promis un
promu on peut les familles les autres
elle parlait un coq et leurs réseaux et
pande d'alcool et pat muntari beck lui
céder ses parts bien aimé faire très
attention ne voit pas tout y est un peu
crado n'est pas attendre et oui mais je
voudrais évidemment il faut pas que ça
colle c'est ça voilà c'est justement si
ça ne bouge pas assez fort que ça risque
de coller voilà bien là on va atteindre
13,1 cuisine qui prennent un sens trahi
je vais faire alors je veux faire la
sauce quillan et encaisse sa création
s'est affirmé comme un dieu fait ok
c'est cool
voilà
bon on n'est pas tout beau givet et
alors là qu'est ce que tu vas faire tu
as les égoutter et les égoutter les
aimons jouer ensemble on les a mouillé
les voilà qui est pour moi ça et oui
c'est chaud même entretien oui mais plus
et ça pour le maintien non j'en fais mon
travail je le fais passer sa première
haie je veux aller à à domi que ça va
plus ou là viendrait il y en a on n'est
pas voulu oui c'est bon c'est possible
pour une place en plus ça y est la
vingtième minute unis ne tombent et
d'huile d'olive allez je n'aime pas ça
tiassalé thonon bien maintenue s'agit
pas besoin de te le dire bien sûr et on
a mis de lui-même jeux de pouvoir dans
le christ si tu n'arrives comme turnover
bien devenu tueur ajoute un peu le
beurre mènera extrême rigueur si tu n'as
rien quand on a créé doucement rire
karin knapp arbre alors tu choisis mes
deux ya les familles il ya les moules
dans les moules pardon et les pro vie
swingue tu les veux commencer par pas
les favoris parce que j'ai entendu crier
les deux autres allez après mon petit
mais écoute alors je sais pas moi les
vallées les clovisses alors si tu veux
c'est pas obligatoire dans l'assiette
si tu veux tu rajoute un peu je sais que
ces excès du second voit aussi à partir
du veut sauf un peu de rythme qui ne
veux pas tu dis oui ninon eh bien je dis
non et benali nord là mais pas celui qui
n'a pas rentré
aulas dans des mois un couvert que je
vais mélanger tout ça un coup vers l'iss
à côté de vous chers la vraie vie je dis
que c'est pas ce rythme croire
j'attends de goûtez moi tu as préparé le
fromage de gruyère râpé le voile jaune
et blanche mais le fromage de parmesan
râpé
oui c'est parti tu vas table très bien
vécu tu as maintenant ça me va tout à
fait l'offre atteint et où il est fait
[Musique]